so last year I ran for mayor of my
hometown Tulsa Oklahoma and I was the
underdog was running against a two-term
incumbent and my opponent ran the
classic partisan playbook he publicized
his endorsement of Donald Trump he
publicized a letter that he sent to
President Obama protesting Syrian
refugees even though none of them were
coming to Tulsa
he ran ads on TV that my kids thought
made me look like Voldemort and sent out
little gems in the mail like this never
mind that America's most liberal labor
union as defined by this ad was actually
the Tulsa firefighters union hardly a
famed bastion of liberalism
never mind that while she was running
for president and he was serving in his
final year in that office Hillary Brock
and I could just never find the time to
get together and yuk it up about the
Tulsa mayor's race never mind
that I like my opponent and a Republican
and so when something like this hits you
in a campaign you have to decide how
you're going to respond and we had a
novel idea what if instead of responding
with partisanship we responded with a
focus on results what if we ran a
campaign that was not about running
against someone but was about bringing
people together behind a common vision
and so we decided to respond not with a
negative ad but with something people
find even sexier data points
and so we emphasize things like
increasing per capita income in our city
increasing our city's population and we
stuck to those relentlessly throughout
the campaign always bringing it back to
those things by which our voters could
measure in a very transparent way how we
were doing and hold me accountable if I
got elected and a funny thing happened
when we did that Tulsa is home to one of
the most vibrant young professional
populations in the country and they took
notice of this approach we have in our
culture in our city an ethos where our
business leaders don't just run
companies they run philanthropic
institutions and nonprofits and those
folks took notice we have parents who
are willing to sacrifice today so that
their kids can have a better future and
those people took notice too and so on
Election Day
I GT Bynum a guy whose name reminds
people of a circus promoter a guy with
the raw animal magnetism of a young
Orville Redenbacher I won the election
by 17 points and we did it with the
support of Republicans and Democrats now
why is that story in that approach so
novel why do we always allow ourselves
to fall back on philosophical
disagreements that ultimately lead to
division I believe it is because
politicians find it easier to throw the
red meat out to the base than to
innovate the conventional wisdom is that
to win an election
you have to dumb it down and play to
your constituencies basest divisive
instincts and when somebody wins an
election like that they win that's true
but the rest of us lose and so what we
need to do is think about how can we
change that dynamic how
can we move to in a direction where
partisanship is replaced with policy and
fortunately there's a growing bipartisan
movement across this country that is
doing just that one of its heroes is a
guy named Mitch Daniels mitch Daniels
served as george w bush's budget
director and during that time he created
what was called the park tool the part
tool allowed people to evaluate a broad
range of federal programs and apply
numerical scoring for them on things
like program management and project
results and using this they evaluated
over a thousand federal programs over a
hundred and fifty programs had their
funding reduced because they could not
demonstrate success but unfortunately
there wasn't ever a well-publicized
increase in funding for those programs
that did demonstrate success and because
of this the program was never really
popular with Congress and was eventually
shuttered but the spirit of that program
lived on mitch daniels went home to
indiana ran for governor got elected and
applied the same premise to state
programs reducing funding for those
programs that could not demonstrate
success but this time he very publicly
increased funding for those programs
that could demonstrate success things
like increasing the number of state
troopers that they needed to have
reducing wait times at the DMV and today
mitch daniels is the president of Purdue
University applying yet again the same
principles this time at the higher ed
level and he's done that in order to
keep tuition levels for students they're
flat for half a decade now while mitch
Daniels applied this at the federal
level the state level and in higher ed
the guy that really cracked the code for
cities is a Democrat martin O'Malley
during his time as mayor Baltimore and
when Mara Malley took office he was a
big fan of what they've been able to do
in New York City when it came to
fighting crime when Rudy Giuliani first
became mayor of New York crime
statistics were collected on a monthly
even an annual basis and then Polly
resources would be allocated based on
those statistics Giuliani shrunk that
time frame so that crime statistics
would be collected on a daily even
hourly basis and then police resources
would be allocated to those areas
quickly where crimes were occurring
today rather than where they were
occurring last quarter well a Mallee
loved that approach and he applied it in
Baltimore he applied it to the area to
areas that were most problematic for
Baltimore from a crime-fighting
standpoint we call these the kidneys of
death so there they are the kidneys now
watch this watch what happens when you
apply data in real-time and deploy
resources quickly in a decade they
reduce violent crime in Baltimore by
almost 50% using this approach but the
genius of what O'Malley did was not that
he just did what some other city was
doing lots of us mayor's do that he
realized that the same approach could be
used to all of the problems that his
city faced and so they applied it to
issue after issue in Baltimore and today
it's being used by mayor's across the
country to deal with some of our
greatest challenges and the overall
approach is a very simple one identify
the goal that you want to achieve
identify a measurement by which you can
track progress toward that goal identify
a way of testing that measurement
cheaply and quickly and then deploy
whatever strategies you think would work
test them reduce funding for the
strategies that don't work and put your
money into those strategies that do
today Atlanta is using this to address
housing issues for their homeless
population
Philadelphia's use this to reduce their
crime rates to levels not enjoyed since
the 1960s Louisville has used this not
just for their city but in a
community-wide effort bringing resources
together to address vacant and abandoned
properties and I am using this approach
in Tulsa
I want Tulsa to be a world-class City
and we cannot do that if we aren't clear
in what our goals are and we don't use
evidence and evaluation to accomplish
them now what's interesting and we've
found in implementing this a lot of
people when you talk about data people
think of that as a contrast to
creativity what we found is actually
quite the opposite we found it to be an
engine for creative problem-solving
because when you're focused on a goal
and you can test different strategies
quickly the sky's the limit on the
different things that you can test out
you can come up with any strategy that
you can come up with and utilize it and
try and test it until you find something
that works and then you double down on
that the other area that we found that
it is lends itself to creativity is that
it breaks down those old silos of
ownership that we run into so often in
government it allows you to draw all the
stakeholders in your community that care
about homelessness or crime fighting or
education or vacant abandoned properties
in a and bring those people to the table
so you can work together to address your
common goal now until so we're applying
this to things that are common city
initiatives things like is you've heard
now repeatedly public safety that's an
obvious one improving our employee
morale at the city we don't think you
can do good things unless you've got
happy employees improving the overall
street quality throughout our community
but we're also applying it to things
that are not so traditional when you
think about what cities are responsible
for things like increasing per capita
income increasing our population
improving our high school graduation
rates and perhaps the greatest challenge
that we face as a city at the dawn of
the 1920s Tulsa was home to the most
vibrant african-american community in
the country
it was known the Greenwood section of
our city was known as black Wall Street
in 1921 in one night Tulsa experienced
the worst race riot in American
three black Wall Street was burned to
the ground and today a child that is
born in the most predominantly
african-american part of our city is
expected to live 11 years less than a
kid that's born elsewhere in Tulsa now
for us this is a unifying issue four
years from now we will recognize the
100th commemoration of that awful event
and in Tulsa we are bringing every tool
that we can to address that life
expectancy disparity and we're not
checking party registration cards at the
door to the meetings we don't care who
you voted for for president if you want
to help restore the decade of life
that's being stolen from these kids
right now and so we've got white folks
and black folks Hispanic folks in Native
American folks we've got members of
Congress members of the City Council
business leaders religious leaders Trump
people and Hillary people all joined by
one common belief and that is that a kid
should have an equal shot at a good life
in our city regardless of what part of
town they happen to be born in now how
do we go forward with that is that easy
to accomplish of course not
if it were easy to accomplish somebody
would have already done it before us but
what I love about city government is
that the citizens can create whatever
kind of city they're willing to build
and in Tulsa we have decided to build a
city where Republicans and Democrats use
evidence data and evaluation to solve
our greatest challenges together and if
we can do this if we can set
partisanship aside in the only state in
the whole country where Barack Obama
never carried a single County then you
can do it in your town to your cities
can be saved or squandered in one
generation
so let's agree to set aside our
philosophical disagreements and focus on
those aspirations that unite us
let's grasp the opportunity that is
presented by innovation to build better
communities for our neighbors let's
replace a focus on partisan division
with the focus on results that is the
path to a better future for us all thank
you for your time
[Applause]
[Music]